I stay in so many different shapes and
and forms over the entire process of
from let's definitely needed that to be
at the very beginning I wanted to write
a short story about lowlifes like these
three lowlifes letters and ina brain the
short story and I liked it but it was it
was it was ridiculous to think that I
could turn that into at the time to turn
it into a script was very complex seen
what I mean it was just justiça Lee it
wasn't go work so I then me I wrote a
bunch of sketches out you know maybe 140
pages worth of sketches and with the
same characters and of just things that
either I had experienced or or things
I'd experienced then they're highly
fictionalized and I just concentrate
Mahlon like what was making what I found
humorous and in the scenes and it would
just keep focusing on if it made me
laugh then I'd keep it and over many
years and many reef writes it turned
into once it started taking a different
shape I then realized that i was
actually making fun of myself in a lot
of ways and other people and just
conversation it sort of was a comer it
was a a it was a grouping of all those
things like and the story became more so
about how I see you how you see me how
we see strangers loved ones family
members friends and how it's sort of
very ridiculous to sub just to a certain
extent that we
that we believe what we think or that we
even consider that we might know what
the other person actually is about and I
the script became at least was fueled by
that idea the absurdity of identity and
Justin my weird jaded way of talking to
strangers uh or not in talking strange
button and considering the conversation
itself that goes on between people you
know that base that ultimately feel the
the script and an elephant story when
you were writing it did you have certain
people in line for the cast did you know
all the people or did you assemble the
cast later you know something from back
home yeah yeah we had one of our post
friends and he cheated on he's also
roommate here um there's no he's in him
yeah he went to college with me as well
and uh he was just so he was always
gonna be the script I just was thinking
in the in the screenplay I thought you
know he could nuovo just play he'll play
the role if we can't find anybody or
we'll find ohhh we'll find whoever
friend wise to put it into these roles
so the simple answer your question is no
I didn't have anybody in mind when I was
writing these these are these characters
on it as it continued develop it was
more so just the characters making I
mean it was me making fun of the
circumstantial interactions like
dysfunctional parents are ya dysfunction
parents but I mean
I think those those things just sort of
come in to attempt to climbing and the
script because you need someone of a
story it for me it's a lot it really is
more about the dialogue and just this
weird i don't i mean it's it's
inexplicable to me how we have
conversations and how we communicate and
then think we understand again what it
is that is being said it's more so it's
more it's more than me having fun with
those ideas and where would you write
like what would you be at home afraid
your computer or customer oh you know
whatever right at the time I actually
didn't have a computer uh-huh when I
first read it I take ready maybe I'm
selectors no no that I wish I I wrote it
out on on just pages and i'm on paper
then typed in a computer but it was
somebody else's computer so then I had
to like walk around with a dry for a
little while because then having a
computer so I had the book of the script
the notebook was a drive so and then I
finally got a computer many years later
and was able to UM then work on it and
which was a lot easier but may effort
purse for a little while was with the
Gettysburg Address yeah and I mean I
would work for her not him um that
worked at jo sales worked up my house
with the coffee shop park beach I walk
I'll I mean on everywhere
you